- David Oyelowo is maybe one of the most
charming actors to join me on this stage.
It's so easy to hang on
to every word he says,
just look back at his visit here
and you'll see what I mean.
But is it true that your dad was a king?
- Ah, well, my grandfather was a king.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- My dad was a-
- What!?
- [David] Yeah, yeah.
- That's so cool.
- It is cool.
- [Kelly] Wait, or not or what? (laughs)
- No, it is cool!
Well, because you know,
when I was growing up,
you know, I was growing up in the UK,
you think of the royal family as the Queen
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- and you know, it's Buckingham
palace and all of that.
And so my dad, you know, my
dad had these tribal marks.
He had four tribal marks on his face
and he told me that when he was younger,
he fought a tiger,
which is why he had these tribal marks.
And I thought, oh, okay.
So whenever I would go to school,
I'd be like, don't touch
me, don't bully me,
because my dad for a tiger and survived,
so don't mess with me.
- (laughs) So!
- But he would also tell me
that we were a royal
family back in Nigeria.
And I was more ready
to believe in the tiger
than the royal family, because
I had the royal family.
I was like, there's no way
we're like the royal family!
So we then moved back to
Nigeria when I was about six
and all my relatives came to
pick us up from the airport
and all the men had
apparently fought a tiger.
(David, Kelly, and audience laughs)
- So I was like, but dad, are
there even tigers in Nigeria?
But weirdly that was the lie.
- [Kelly] Lies!
- The truth was that we were actually all
from a royal family and we
lived on Oyelowo street,
and my family and all them.
- [Kelly] Wow.
Part of Western Nigeria called Awe
is where we are the royal family of.
- That is so cool!
(audience clapping)
We also got to talking
about David's life at home
and he is quite the family man.
Here's something we've never shown before.
Are any of your kids driving yet?
Are you terrified?
By the way, your family is beautiful!
- [David] Thank you.
- You're like the family in the
photos when you buy a frame.
(everyone laughs)
It's unreal.
- Maybe we should do
that, like a side hustle.
- I'm just saying, yeah.
If it doesn't work out, there's your job.
- Exactly. Thank you.
Thank you for saying that.
Yeah, my eldest son is now 19.
He does drive. He's a
very responsible driver.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- But my second son is
15 and that's Caleb.
Oh, there he is. (laughs)
You can tell, yeah, the one
giving you the peace sign.
- [Kelly] Yes.
= That's my 15 year old Caleb.
He's the one I'm a little
bit more concerned about.
- I mean, from the photo,
I would be too. (laughs)
- [David] Yeah, exactly.
- He's someone fun, like playful.
- He has a talent for breaking things.
- [Kelly] Ah.
- You know, things, himself.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And so we have decided
that he has got to go
a full year without breaking anything
before he's allowed to drive.
- Oh my God, you definitely
break a lot of things
when that's a rule.
- Yeah, well, exactly.
And we don't want him breaking
himself or the car, in a car.
And so that's why we've
decided to do that.
So he keeps on, he keeps
on shifting (chuckles)
- [Kelly] He's never going to drive.
- Because he keeps on breaking things.
- He was like, whatever. I'll Uber.
Do you, quick question from that picture,
do you all just get together and work out?
(everyone laughs)
Like I just saw that picture
and this wasn't even
supposed to be a question,
but I was like, what do
y'all do, workouts together?
Like, you're all like very fit.
- We actually do.
We're blessed enough
to have a gym at home.
- I have a gym at home!
- (chuckling) Oh, really?
- I have a gym at home, okay?
Not everybody with a gym
at home looks like that.
(everyone continues laughing)
I'm just saying that
doesn't always pan out.
So what's your secret?
- Oh, man. Well, I don't know.
As an actor, I sort of think
of actors as athletes as well.
I have to change my body a lot.
- Oh, that's why I can
never be an actor. (laughs)
- [David] Ah, see. There you go.
- It's not for me.
- [David] You could be. I
could see you doing that.
No, actually in the Midnight Sky,
I had to do about three
months of training.
- [Kelly] Wow!
- For all the spacewalk stuff,
because you had to get a very strong core
because it's all wire work.
And in order to look like you're floating,
you actually have to, you know,
really be employing a lot of effort.
- I just pictured me doing
it. (everyone laughs)
It wasn't as graceful.
- It's really painful, the
harness is right up in here
so I'm glad I had my four kids first.
- [Kelly] Yeah. You
should try Spanx, my man.
(everyone laughs)
I'm used to tight there.
Is it true that you kept chickens at home?
- I do!
- [Kelly] I had chickens
when I was in Tennessee.
I don't have them here,
but do you love it?
Y'all love it?
- Yeah, they provide eggs.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
They provide entertainment.
(Kelly laughs)
We got them at the
beginning of the pandemic.
We thought, okay, let's
get closer to the earth.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we now have every form of egg,
omelet, scrambled egg, anything.
- [Kelly] I love it!
- We now know everything
you can do with an egg.
(audience laughs)
- Yes, same thing.
I love the fact that you're
self-sustaining as well.
That's cool.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Makes
you feel like a man!
Collecting eggs.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah. I am like
the people back then.
I can do everything. I'm
a gatherer and hunter.
- [David] Yeah, exactly.
- Well, I think we have a little video
of you with your chickens.
- [David] Oh yeah, I
did the video for you.
- Yes.
- Okay, so as promised,
I'm going to introduce you to my chickens.
They all have interesting names.
That's Slough.
(audience laughs)
I think that's Potato, that's Star.
That's Aubergine...
and that's Rona.
(audience laughs)
And then one of them is
called Untitled Project.
(everyone laughing)
- Untitled Project, you're awesome.